today on the matt walsh show lots of
coveted quote-unquote misinformation has
suddenly become information because
fauci and the media are now saying it
we'll talk about that miraculous
transformation today and i'll tell you
all about my own harrowing encounter
with the dreaded omnicorn variant but uh
twitter has ramped up its censorship
campaign against covet heretics even as
many of their claims have been proven
true so we've got to talk about that
also also alexandria quezada cortez says
that all of her critics really just want
to date her and the left uncover is a
shocking truth about ron desantis you're
not going to believe this plus the top
female jeopardy contestant of all time
is a man and in our daily cancellation
we'll deal with the atlantic writer who
blew up her marriage because she was
bored and believes that she has
discovered some deep truths about life
from her experience all of that and more
today on the matte wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
now a quick word from lifelock have you
ever heard of scare wear well just like
it sounds it's a scam that uses scare
tactics in the form of pop-up ads to get
users to believe that their computer has
a security problem and the fixes to
purchase and or download you know
software which ends up being a scam
cyber criminals can then gain access to
your computer and steal your personal
information uh at will at that point
this is just one of the ways that every
day we put our information at risk on
the internet in an instant a cyber
criminal could steal what's yours
sometimes even harm your finances your
credit your reputation
all of that that's why it's so good that
there is lifelock lifelock helps detect
a wide range of identity threats uh
things that you might not know about on
your own might not be able to detect
like if your social security number is
for sale on the dark web if they detect
that your information has been
compromised they'll send you an alert
they'll let you know and you also have
access to a dedicated restoration
specialist if you do god forbid become a
victim nobody can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can help protect
what's yours with lifelock by norton
join now and save up to 25 off your
first year at lifelock.comwalsh that's
lifelock.com walsh for 25 off
you know the new year is a time for deep
reflection for resolution for learning
lessons and making goals for the future
at least that's what most people seem to
think it's never been very clear to me
why you should wait until the arbitrary
point when the calendar flips over to a
new year to do all of those things in
fact if you're waiting that's pretty
good indication that you aren't serious
the only serious resolutions and most
resolutions are not serious at all no
matter when they're made but the only
potentially serious ones are those that
are acted upon
the moment that they're made and the
most serious of all are the resolutions
that are not made out loud but are just
done with no festivities or fireworks
and that's the end of it so you want to
start working out okay we'll do some
push-ups you want to stop eating junk
okay put down the french fries
start what you want to start now stop
what you want to stop now all things
have to be done in the present anyway if
you're not willing to do them in the
present moment and instead are waiting
for the new year or for monday or for
next week or whatever then there's no
reason to think that when that future
time becomes the present time that
you'll actually follow through
but if i were to humbly suggest a couple
of resolutions that you might we might
we all might adopt this year resolutions
that can be implemented immediately and
might help restore perhaps a small
amount of sanity to our society in 2022
they would be number one
to re-learn how to use and how to trust
your common sense
now we've witnessed in our age an
unprecedented assault on common sense
people have forgotten how to make sound
judgments in practical matters which is
what we mean by common sense or else
they've been so battered into mental
submissions so bewildered and confused
that they're too afraid to listen to
their own intuition we see this at work
in you know the sorts of areas we talk
about all the time on this show like
when it comes to gender but it's it's
been even more pronounced with respect
to the covet panic
where early on we were forbidden from
saying common sense things about the
situation but now one by one
each of those once forbidden common
sense observations or intuitions have
been vindicated
and slowly permitted into the discourse
once it's been approved by a ranking
member of the thought police for example
many of us have been saying for years
that you're probably not achieving much
by putting a thin layer of cloth over
your face when you go out in public
if the goal is to look silly then
mission accomplished but if the goal is
to prevent an airborne virus from
infecting you then you might be in for a
rude awakening now such ideas were
verboden harmful dangerous conspiracy
mongering until just a few days ago when
the wall street journal published a
piece titled why cloth masks might not
be enough as omicron spreads
who would have thought well a lot of us
thought but we couldn't say it another
example many of us have been saying not
saying like shouting screaming at the
top of our lungs in increasingly
desperate fashion that we are harming
our children by depriving them of a
normal life for fear of a virus that
poses very little risk to them
this seemed like a common sense judgment
and also a morally sensible judgment but
was condemned as psychotic suicidal
reckless
until the thought police on cnn started
saying it themselves
so right before christmas brian stelter
had exactly this epiphany and of course
he communicates it as though he's the
first person to ever say it listen
in some media circles this was the week
where
getting covid became an
inevitability that there's this
acceptance that everybody is going to
get covered eventually tens of millions
of americans already have and everybody
else is going to at some point
is that the proper approach just to
accept that at some point you'll be
infected which doesn't mean you'll get
sick doesn't mean you'll suffer but at
some point everyone will be infected
is that the proper approach now
and if so why is it still so hard to
find at-home tests
especially in blue america by the way
pro tip if you want to find at-home
tests get somebody in red america in a
red state to mail them to you since all
the stores at least here in new york
that i've seen are sold out
and here's another question since we're
hearing about schools closing again
we collectively took action to protect
the elderly in 2020
now shouldn't we be doing more to
protect children
by letting them live normal lives
are we really going to let the kids
suffer even more
wow how'd you think of that brian lots
of people on the right applauded stelter
for that when he said it a couple weeks
ago um i do not applaud him
if you're wrong for two years about
something as serious as this and then
suddenly you switch over to the right
team without even giving any credit to
the people who arrived at that
conclusion two years ahead of you
and provided you all the cover to say it
now you're not gonna get a pat on the
back for me
you shouldn't get it from anybody this
goes doubly for anthony fauci who went
on msnbc on new year's eve
and finally admitted and this is pretty
amazing in some ways
finally admitted that the covet
hospitalization numbers are perhaps
perhaps
not what they first appear
listen
many of them are hospitalized with covid
as opposed to because
of covid and what we mean by that if a
child goes in the hospital they
automatically get tested for kovid and
they get counted as a covet hospitalized
individual when in fact they may go in
for a broken leg or appendicitis or
something like that
so it's over counting the number of
children who are quote hospitalized with
covid as opposed to because of coving
well this is this is this is
dangerous he just said that there are
kids in the hospital potentially with
broken legs
who are counted as hospitalized as as
covet hospitalizations
but what he's saying is not everybody
hospitalized with kovid
is actually hospitalized because of
covet
see this again is an argument that we've
been making for two years
only we had to be very careful in making
that argument because everything tony
just said there would have gotten you
banned from most social media platforms
maybe it still will
maybe me repeating what he just said
will get this show taken down from
youtube i don't know
see sometimes if a ranking member of the
thought police says something
it sometimes means that everyone else is
allowed to say it too but often the
exception doesn't extend beyond that one
individual
so there's a lot that a guy like tony
fauci is allowed to say which the rest
of us are not i mean he is the science
after all the science can say and do
what it wants
those are the rules anyway
but we shouldn't make mistake the rules
for the truth
common sense has been vindicated time
and time again remember that
the other resolution is i think even
more important
and that is to stop living in fear
i mean it's been a bad idea to let fear
rule your life in general
but fear over covid is at this point
especially delusional
now i can speak with some experience now
like almost everybody else in america it
seems i had my turn with omnicorn over
the break
which was good because frankly i was
starting to feel a little bit left out
and um the illness began for me as a
sort of vague feeling
that i was coming down with something
and then for two days i had a mild fever
and i felt pretty you know miserable
and then the fever went away and i felt
almost completely fine save for a
scratchy throat and an occasional
sniffle
and and that was it now it's not true
it's it's not true
not true
that omnicorn is like the flu
in my experience anyway it wasn't nearly
as bad as that i've had the flu
i actually did go to the hospital for
the flu a couple years ago
and my experience may be anecdotal but
it's far from unusual omnicorn has been
incredibly mild for the vast majority of
people
so so what have i learned after
surviving this um
tremendous ordeal well after trudging
through the fires of a 100.5 degree
fever and a runny nose and a headache
um i have learned
absolutely nothing that i didn't already
know i was sick
then i got better
you know that's how it works usually
sickness exists in the world
viruses not only exist but there are
more viruses on earth than there are
stars in the sky
many of those viruses belong to the 200
some species that could potentially
infect humans
and some of them are far worse than
covet some not as bad
they're also like 100 different kinds of
cancer
and over half a million americans die
every year from one type or another
there are countless bacteria floating
around out there some of them resistant
to antibiotic biotics many of them
haven't even been discovered yet
and diseases are just one sort of danger
every time you drive a car you're
trusting and hoping that you're not
going to cross paths with any of the
lethally drunk or distracted drivers
that happen to be out on the road at the
same time as you
maybe your gamble will work out maybe
not
even in your house
you're under a roof that could collapse
i mean i am right now
or walking on a floor that could give in
there are murderers out there and serial
killers and terrorists
and armed robbers
and we've only considered the hazards
that currently occupy the earth
alongside you
an asteroid or solar flare could make
all of that irrelevant in an instant
that is unless a super volcano erupts
and does the job first
so my point is happy new year
if you're looking for something to be to
be afraid of this year if you really
need something
there are many more worthy options than
covid and especially omnicorn
but the better option
is to focus on something other than fear
live your life while you can that's the
best resolution i think for all of us
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well here's definitely a resolution you
can make in 2022 don't waste any more
time at auto parts stores there's no
reason to do that when rockauto.com has
everything you need with the ever
increasing numbers of car makes and
models it's now impossible to stock all
the parts you need in a traditional
chain storefront and that's why you it
might be pointless to endure
the the whole hassle of going there and
you've got all the specifications and
everything you need and uh they're not
gonna have it and then what they're
gonna do is they're gonna go on their
computer and order it for you and you
could cut out the middleman and just do
that yourself you have computers with
access to rockauto.com at home and in
your pocket so just use that instead why
would you choose to spend 30 50 100 more
for the exact same auto parts at a chain
store or the new car dealership down the
street no reason to do that rockauto.com
is available to you rockauto.com is a
family business they've been serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com right now to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
they're the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need at rockauto.com go to
rockauto.com right now and see all the
parts available for your car truck write
walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so they know that we sent you
so a couple of other important notes
from the break first um that that i i
was uh for the first time in my life
i was given the very important and
sacred duty
of making the cookies for santa and um i
wanted to show you these because here's
a
i've never baked anything in my life and
for some reason you know we santa's
coming so you got to make the cookies
and uh
and
so my wife said to me can you make the
you know the cookies for santa and i did
and you can see there how those turned
out
you might say that i put the duty in
sacred duty with this effort i mean not
literally i didn't i mean i didn't i
wouldn't do that to santa
um
and uh there's and i was mocked
relentlessly for these cookies by
everybody in the house we had family
over
my wife kept asking how the cookies
ended up this way these are supposed to
be gingerbread men by the way um so and
i and i and and but it's it's not
supposed to look like someone texas
chainsaw massacred a bunch of obese
snowmen but that's how it turned out
and so my wife kept saying how did this
happen and like i don't know i had the
dough
and i used the cookie cutter thing and
then this is what happened
but santa did end up somehow he still
left presents for the kids so and then
the new year came and uh some people
were still sick in the house so we
stayed in though of course we would have
stayed in anyway because we're boring
and
we let the kids stay up until midnight
so this was their first time staying up
till midnight on new year's
and that was a decision
that i regretted by about five in the
afternoon because it was at four o'clock
when the kids said to me daddy can we
stay up till midnight on new year's this
time
and for some reason i said yeah sure
and an hour later i regretted it so we
just we stayed up all you know until
midnight and
kids get so excited about that but of
course as an adult
when it gets to midnight all you're
doing is you're running the calculations
of how much sleep you're going to get
everything's a math problem and you're
negotiating with your future self like
well i can do 30 more minutes here i'll
take 30 minutes off the back end but uh
the kids were were
really excited and then and we sat we
watched the ball drop
and then we um
my wife's idea was that they're gonna
let she was gonna let the kids go
outside and uh scream happy new year in
the neighborhood and so that's what we
did at midnight so my apologies to the
to my neighbors for that one
all right um
we'll start with this last week dr
robert malone was permanently suspended
from twitter for alleged covet
misinformation now he's been called an
anti-vaxxer and a conspiracy theorist
uh even though he's a doctor he's an
immunologist he's a virologist he's been
heavily involved in researching and
developing vaccines
so he's a he's a leading expert in the
world
on the subject
but they banned him because he raises
questions and concerns that fall outside
of the accepted narrative
and a couple days later he appeared on
joe rogan's show and the whole episode i
very rarely promote other people's
podcasts unless they're paying me to um
joe rogan of course is not but this is a
an episode worth watching the whole
thing is where it's like three hours
long listen to the whole thing
but i want to play just a couple of
clips for you and um just a few choice
uh bits here that i think are important
so first here is uh
dr robert malone talking about
the pharmaceutical industry especially
pfizer
and the conflicts of interest that you
deal with when it comes to the
pharmaceutical industry listen to this
well that's one of the more disturbing
things the the opposite of that is one
of the more disturbing things about this
pandemic is how people
have just decided because they're scared
and because they want a solution that
the pharmaceutical companies have their
best interests at hearts and that
they're not these
machines that are designed to make money
and they they sell drugs and the drugs
are often beneficial but their main goal
is to make money and if they can fudge
the data if they can move the numbers
around if they can delete negative
consequences pfizer is
one of the most criminal pharmaceutical
organizations in the world based on
their past legal history
and fines
one of those fines include
bribing physicians
okay it is a cost benefit analysis in
the pharmaceutical industry about
misbehavior
they are not grounded in the ethical
principles that you and i
as average people believe in
they don't live in that world as you
appropriately point out
they are about profit return on
investment
and furthermore
the overlords that own them
blackrock vanguard state street etc
these large massive funds that are
completely decoupled from nation states
have no moral core they have no moral
purpose
their only purpose is return on
investment
so not nothing that you just heard there
is although of course it's condemned as
conspiracy theories and
there's there's nothing conspiratorial
about it
there's nothing especially shocking
about it actually
um
we know it's a simple fact of life we
know that money corrupts
and uh these pharmaceutical industries
are multi-billion dollar
corporations there's a lot of money at
stake and that's going to create
conflicts of interest and it seems
interesting at first that
you know on the left
if you didn't know any better and you're
maybe a little bit more naive you might
expect
that criticisms of the pharmaceutical
industry would be they'd be kind of a
bipartisan
deal
or people on both sides of the aisle can
agree
because we know that people on the right
tend to be skeptical the pharmaceutical
industry to a certain extent and then
people on the left it's it's this is a
major corporation with billions of
dollars
and you're supposed to be skeptical of
all of them
and for good reason by the way
and yet it seems that um
the left this is one multi-billion
dollar industry that they'll circle the
wagons around
and say oh no not them
and that might seem interesting at first
or confusing but then you realize
that uh you know from the leftist point
of view big pharma
you know these are basically the priests
these are the
the uh the witch doctors
of the human condition because the human
condition from the left's point of view
is entirely a medical problem
and every problem that you have
can be solved through through medicine
you need big pharma for that
so any and that's that goes beyond
viruses
any
uncomfortable emotion or thought
or or a personality trait
that you don't want will you just go to
big pharma and they'll solve it for you
you know everything from
despair to anxiety everything can be
solved through through a big pharma
if you don't like
the biological identity that you were
born with you can go to big pharma and
they'll solve that problem for you
so you have to understand how the left
views
the pharmaceutical industry
they do they do view it in a in a kind
of religious light
and that is primarily why they cannot
brook any criticism
of uh of the pharmaceutical industry all
right one uh so a couple others here
that i wanted to play for you that i
think are interesting so here is
robert malone's clip three
talking about the ways that hospitals
are incentivized
um
when it comes to covet and this this
these are his claims this is what he's
saying as someone who has a lot of
background knowledge
and i think it's important for us all to
hear it here's what he says
the observation that i can make if we
follow the money
is that hospitals are incentivized to to
treat covet patients
the thing that ties all this little part
of this story together including the
suppression through the government
of early treatment
hospitals are incentivized financially
to treat covet patients if coveted
patients are being treated outside of
the hospital and prevented from going to
the hospital
such as the case in the imperial valley
where brian tyson and george fareed have
saved thousands and thousands of lives
of indigenous latinos that are coming
across the border and working the fields
i mean they're breaking their backs to
save the poor amazing story there with
early treatments
um
and i guess they're left alone because
they're in the imperial valley nobody
cares they're all poor but in these
urban environments there's all these
incentives for hospitals
to treat covet patients and if people
are giving treatments that are keeping
those people out of the hospitals then
they're not getting that revenue so your
speculation if i just
could unpack this that doctor in maui
who was giving
early treatment
you re you think that the reason why he
was targeted because he was directly
costing the hospital money because
people weren't going in i'm not saying i
i'm saying that the observation is that
early treatment keeps people out of the
hospital and that hospitals have
financial incentives
including death incentives to discourage
early treatment
that's outrageous i wish i hadn't played
that i'm sorry um he said latinos which
is very offensive
latinx is what he means but here again
we hear about the the
potential conflicts of interest
that could arise
um
and he also talks about how according to
him
he alleges
that
you know there's this there's this
intense focus on
the so-called preventative what's
supposed to be preventative measures
like like vaccines
but um what about treatment after the
fact i mean what about what about actual
therapeutics we don't hear as much about
that
he alleges that there's been an effort
to suppress that information
and there might be financial reasons for
that there could also be political
reasons
i think personally i would guess if
that's going on a big part of it is
political
because trump
early on was talking about
you know ivermectin and those sorts of
things and
as soon as trump says it
then
well that can't be the answer because
trump said it
so one other clip this is kind of a
longer one but i think but this this to
me of of everything that was said in the
whole
three-hour conversation
this to me to me this was the headline
uh so this clip four uh he he's talking
about a province in india
where they've basically shut down
remember joe biden said he's gonna shut
down kovid and you might notice that it
has not been shut down because cases are
higher than they've ever been well in
one province in india they have
basically shut it down they've crushed
it
but we're not being told what exactly
they did which is which is sort of
interesting listen
pradesh as you know has crushed covet
yeah to explain what they did to do that
because it's kind of fascinating it's
it's not clear
um what are the drugs so what they did
do what we do know and there there's
some backstory to this that we could go
into if you want to but the observation
is there was a decision made the virus
was just ripping through uttar pradesh
it has almost the same populations the
united states it's huge okay um dense
urban poor all the characteristics of
the stereotypes of the indian
countryside um and the virus is just
ripping through there and causing all
kinds of death and disease and the
decision was made out of desperation in
that province to deploy early treatments
as packages
widely throughout the province and it
included a number of agents
the composition has not been formally
disclosed
it was done in coordination with unite
with
who
and
whatever was in those packages
was rumored to include ivermectin
but there was a specific visit of biden
to modi
and um a decision was made in the indian
government not to disclose the contents
of those packages that were being
deployed in uttar pradesh which they're
still there and utter pradesh is
flatlined right now the rest of the
world is yelling about omicron and and
and hospitalizations well south africa
isn't but uh uttar pradesh is still
flatlined in terms of deaths so they
were visited by someone in the body
administration
there's a meeting between joe biden and
um modi and you believe that out of that
meeting
i don't know what they said i didn't
wasn't invited all i know is that
immediately afterwards there was a
decision not to disclose the contents of
what was being deployed in huda
production it's so crazy to imagine that
in the middle of a pandemic there's one
place a one area of india that's
extremely successful in combating the
virus and they're not going to say how
they did it
i mean that's that's nuts that's i you
know so that's that's where i kind of
my stance in all of this is to say here
are the facts here the verifiable data
draw your own conclusion
so there you go um
so what do you what do you do with with
information like this does it mean that
um
you can't trust anything anyone ever
says about this doesn't mean that you we
just you abandon pharmaceuticals and
everyone i'm not i i am
never very quick to grab a bottle of
pills but you know i take tylenol if i
have a headache every once in a while
so are you gonna say well i'm never
gonna
uh everything that big pharma does is
bad well that would be absurd too
no i think what we do with this
information
or the right response
is should be to let everything out in
the open and to have these conversations
openly
let people with different perspectives
let guys like robert malone say his
piece
and then once all the information is
presented and you've got all the
different sides
might be it might seem kind of
bewildering but you've got you know
and now there's potentially at least a
chance
of arriving at some kind of a conclusion
as an adult based on all the information
and you could decide what your own
risk calculus is going to be
that would be the right thing to do but
the problem is that that's that isn't
being allowed
you know big tech shuts it down they say
well this is not allowed you're not
allowed to hear it's not because it's
not necessarily because what you're
hearing there is false
it's just that from their perspective
it might lead you to the conclusions
that they don't want you to uh to arrive
at
and so that's why
he got kicked off of twitter
congresswoman marjorie taylor green was
was also kicked off of twitter that's
the most the most recent thing
she was kicked off of twitter yesterday
after supposedly committing whatever it
is four or five strikes it always
changes
and what are her her violations
well just because she has an opinion
about all of this that um
that might sway people in a direction
that our big tech overlords don't want
them to be swayed
you know another thing we have to
consider here is is we look at like we
talked to to start the show about
all of these sort of common sense
judgments
common sense observations that many of
us have been making for years
and um
we were shouted down and condemned
and now they're circling back around
brian stelter fauci the cdc they say oh
you know maybe there might be something
to some of that
only they're not phrasing it like that
because they don't want to give us
credit
and what we find is that the
especially early on many of the
so-called public health experts many of
the doctors failed us
and why is that well one of the reasons
is a site if we if we're to put aside
political partisanship and everything
else and that's of course a big part of
the
the equation
but um
one of the reasons
is that we were turning to doctors to
answer questions that are outside of
their purview
so in an ideal scenario in an ideal
scenario if you're talking to a doctor
who you can trust
and he doesn't have any conflicts of
interests and he's not a political hack
what what he what he might be able to
tell you is that okay
if you engage in in this activity
um here is the the physical risk that
might come with that so if you go and
gather with your family on christmas
the degree of risk from covid is going
to be xyz
so doctors can do that and and and
again if you could trust them if they're
trustworthy doctors we could call them
an expert in that area
of assessing that sort of physical risk
as it relates to
this or that activity
okay fine
but what doctors can't tell you
once they've given you the risk
which is just an estimate anyway right
it's a guess but they've given you the
risk
what they can't do is tell you whether
the risk is worth it
because that's not a medical judgment
that's a philosophical judgment
so pulling a number out of thin air
gathering with your family on christmas
if there was a i don't know
three percent chance that you would get
coveted doing that
uh maybe you could look at the
statistics and you could figure out what
the exact percentage chance is fine
well
is that three percent risk worth it
is that a worthwhile risk
is the potential cost
worth what you would gain
who who's an expert on that that's
something that can only be that can only
be an individual judgment
because it's your own life your own
family and these are the things you're
weighing
and it is again at the end of the day uh
a uh a philosophical
judgment now i would say 100
definitely worth the risk
we got together with our families
you know in my family we got together
with family on christmas
and uh we all got covered okay
was it worth it
definitely
if i could go back in time and just
cancel christmas ahead of time so that i
didn't get covered would i do it no
what did we gain out of it well we got
to be with our families on christmas
you know our our children got to
celebrate christmas
you only get so many christmases as a
kid
it was a very it's a very precious time
so was that worth the physical pain that
was relatively mild that came after it
yeah
for me
for our family but that's a judgment you
have to make on your own
and so this is the con this is the
conflation that's been going on for
years now
where the where we're supposed to turn
to doctors not just to tell us the you
know the the data and the numbers and
all of that and the percentages
but also to to to give us these
philosophical judgments of whether or
not this or that risk is worth it
you know and that's really a question of
what what sorts of things should you
value the most in your life
should you value physical safety above
everything else
i would say the answer to that is
definitely no
uh and i'm not sure why doctors would
have any special insight into that
all right let's move to this
from the daily wire it says
representative alexandra queza cortez
lashed out at critics on friday after
she was caught hanging out in miami
florida as her city deals with a
record-breaking number of daily
chronovirus cases national review
reported that according to photographs
obtained by the publication kissing
cortez was seated outside
in miami beach
and she was drinking a cocktail she
didn't have a mask on
and she responded to one of her critics
calling her out saying if republicans
are mad they can't date me they can just
say that instead of projecting their
sexual frustrations onto my boyfriend's
feet i guess cause someone made a
comment about the fact that her
boyfriend has ugly feet which it seems
like he does
um then she said you creepy weirdos and
she continued
it's starting to get old ignoring the
very obvious strange and deranged sexual
frustrations
that underpin the republican fixation on
me women and lgbt plus people in general
these people clearly need therapy they
won't do it and they use politics as
their outlet instead it's really weird
and this actually prompted this is a
whole
day-long meltdown on aoc's part where
she was uh insisting that everyone who
criticizes her is actually sexually
attracted to her
and this this stems from two things
number one she is a uh
a very very stupid person
and i certainly don't say that about
everybody on the left i think there are
plenty of
smart people on the left evil
evil but but intelligent
um in the democrat party as well
unfortunately
but that's not the case first she's very
very stupid and she's not able to engage
intellectually
with any point that anybody makes
and so she retreats to the common thing
which is to just label
if you can't engage with an argument
then you simply you label it
and usually we're gonna it's homophobic
it's transphobic it's sexist
and in this case also it's it's it's an
expression of your
deep-seated sexual frustrations
and there's a lot of projection that
goes into that as well
now people on the left they see they see
sexual frustration everywhere they go
in the that is supposedly driving the
behavior of everyone around them
but all we can assume based on that is
that that is that's their own experience
that's how they operate and so they
assume that everyone else operates the
same way
so there's that there's there's
projection there's stupidity and there's
also simply narcissism
you know she she
assumes again that everyone is sexually
attracted to her and so
anytime anyone talks to her says
anything about her it it it must be
fueled by that
narcissistic shallow and uh
and that's what you get from aoc all
right so this is big news i think this
is even bigger news i need to show you
this um a right-wing watchdog group that
is a watchdog group that that watches
the right wing
they've uncovered something quite
sinister related to ron desantis
so this is put up 10a okay so
this is the twitter account patriot
takes
and uh they tweeted out ronda sanders's
family is wearing the exact same clothes
in both their christmas and new year
instagram posts
this is this is stunning
this is a stunning i i think there's
going to be a pole so pull a surprise
for this
this is maybe the great
perhaps the greatest political scandal
certainly of the 21st century
that rhonda sanders's family they're
wearing the same clothing
in in what's going on here exactly and
you you click on that tweet and you read
all the comments underneath it
and it's a bunch of people asking that
what's going on what's what's what is
what's happening what does this all mean
wearing the same clothing and two
different
well
i i just have a one theory here
if i if i could
it could be that there's something
really sinister happening i don't know
or it could be
that ron desantis got his family
together for a photo shoot
and i could guarantee it wasn't his idea
it was his wife's idea it's never the
man's idea so i should say ron desantis
his wife got the family together for a
photo shoot
forced them all there
and then what what they did was they
took multiple photos
and now his social media team is putting
those photos up at various different
times
because what i can tell you from
experience again
is that um
this is one of the reasons why as a man
it'll it'll never be your decision to
take any kind of photo shoot because
it's it's not what i'll talk about cost
benefit analysis never worth the cost
because first you got to get all those
kids in the nice clothing and that's a
whole ordeal
and you've got to the clothing has to
stay nice at least the part that's
visible for the camera has to stay nice
long enough for the pictures to be taken
and that's usually feasible with so he's
got two girls there that's okay you
could put them in nice clothing and uh
let them walk around the house a little
bit and they'll be fine
but with a boy you put him in nice
clothing and within five minutes
it's it looks like he was rolling around
in a barn
so you do all that you keep them clean
you you get them into an environment you
got the photographer there
and to actually get them to look at a
camera and smile
if you can if you can get them in that
the mood where they're actually going to
do that
or you're going to take full advantage
and take as many pictures as you can
especially if your wife is forcing you
so i think that probably explains
how this happened if anyone is is
wondering
all right uh this is from
i guess two weeks ago is
right after our last show here before
christmas eve but i did want to mention
it because we followed this case of kim
potter
who is the officer in the dante dante
wright shooting she was
on trial for manslaughter
for accidentally shooting dante wright
while trying to arrest him after traffic
stop because he was wanted on on a
warrant
for uh for uh
on an illegal weapons warrant which
stems from an armed robbery case and uh
anyway the verdict came down and she was
found guilty of manslaughter
now she's awaiting sentencing and here's
minnesota minnesota attorney general
keith ellison
after the verdict was read
talking about dante wright
and uh he's happy about the verdict of
course but he's he's still very sad
because of
of the kind of man that dante wright
could have turned out to be and and we
are now going to be deprived of dante
wright because of kim potter here's
keith ellison
at this moment
i ask assault to reflect upon the life
of dante wright
and who he could have been had he had a
chance to grow up
at 20
dante could have done anything
maybe he could have gone into the
building trades
maybe he could have started a business
what we know is that he was a young
new dad
and he was so proud of his son dante jr
we know that he loved his mom
and he loved his dad
and he loved his siblings and his big
beautiful family
he had his whole life in front of him
and he could have become anyone
all of us miss out
on who dante could have been
we're we're missing out
that's that's pretty terrible we're
missing out on who dante could have been
well i don't think we need to speculate
very much
because even though he was only what was
it i think he said 20 years old
so a grown man
but a young man and in that short amount
of time
he had robbed a woman at gunpoint while
choking her and sexually assaulting her
he had shot a kid in the face at a gas
station crippling him for life
and he was implicated in at least one
and a carjacking i believe
and those are just the ones we know
about
and that's that's what he did in his
very young life and that was all in the
span of like a year or two a couple
years
so we don't need to speculate uh
what sort of man would he have been who
could he turn well that's that's it
and the thing is generally speaking
when there are no consequences for your
actions
or at least no consequences that are
proportional to what you're doing
most of the time you're not going to
magically convert
into a better person man it can happen
the lord works in mysterious ways
but usually that requires a con some
sort of confrontation
you have to hold people accountable
and we have a justice system that does
not hold people like dante wright
accountable that's how he was still
walking around aft out there
after shooting somebody in the face
and keith allison says we're we're
deprived now communities no
the the sad reality is
that dante wright's community is it's
safer now because dante wright is not in
it
his community is better off
now that he's not in it
that's not my own judgment that's just a
fact
he was a dangerous man who preyed upon
the vulnerable the weak people weaker
than him
so that's that's that that's what's
going on with the community now that
dante wrote isn't there we have a couple
other quick things we got to move on um
a lot of news that we missed uh betty
white died at the age of 99 earlier in
the week john madden died at 85 so that
was those last week
and i bring this up because we got to
think about betty white died at 99
john madden died at 85
the same year
that was all before new year's and the
same year alex trebek died nor macdonald
died
and those were four
of the only
universally beloved figures left in
america and i know that not all of them
were american but we adopted them alex
trebek we adopted
um
so who's left then
i think that leaves us maybe dolly
parton and like denzel washington and
that's it
and i would have put keanu reeves on
that list but i think he's off it now
because of matrix four so
that's it that's all we've got
and there there does something seem to
be something significant about this that
we don't produce in our culture anymore
universally beloved cultural icons that
everybody admires
there are a few that were left because
they were grandfathered in i mean betty
white 99 years old
but i don't think there are any new ones
so once dolly parton and denzel
washington
depart their mortal coil that's i think
that i think that's it
and finally from the daily wire it says
a planned parenthood in knoxville
tennessee uh burned down early friday
morning according to the knoxville news
sentinel fire crews were called about 6
40 a.m as heavy smoke was coming out of
the back of the structure there were no
injuries reported
um the building was being renovated and
uh the clinic it was not being used at
the time but now it's burned down
we don't know exactly
how it happened or what started the fire
and uh you know it's it's a it's a real
shame
but look on the bright side
the building was really just a clump of
bricks when you think about it
so this was the termination of an
unwanted clump of bricks
was it even a building
how do you define building i mean what
is a building exactly
and anyway as our blm friends would say
it was insured so you know
no harm no foul right
that's the bright side of this
let's get out of the comment section
[Music]
okay so it's been a while since we've
done a show so i figured um instead of
going to the youtube comments
i would go to my dms and read some of
those instead because those are more
recent
and so that's what we're going to do
this is from internal saint toku who
says hey matt just wanted to wish you
good luck with coming up with more
stupid in 2022 if you've done such a
good job this year and i'm sure you're
only getting started you'll make so many
people that much dumber with your nearly
unintelligible rambling best luck bud
well thank you i appreciate that i do
sequence says i come from a pretty
broken home and just wanted to know is
it normal for every couple to have an
argument every once in a while so that
you have a good marriage i would love to
know
from yourself
uh yeah it is it's it's in fact we'll
we'll have more on this in the daily
cancellation come up here in a second
but
uh it's not only normal but it's healthy
i i hear from couples sometimes and say
oh we never argue i never argue with my
my spouse
um
that just tells me that one or both of
you probably one of you and probably the
husband that you're keeping your mouth
shut you're not expressing your anger
when you when you feel it or when you're
uncomfortable with something you're not
saying it
so if there's any kind of actual
communication in your marriage there's
going to be arguments
if you're having uh arguments every
single day then that's different but
this is this
in moderation all things in moderation
especially arguments
um
dancing bec says can you can you explain
what should i exist means in your panda
sweatshirt
my husband bought it for my son for
christmas but neither one of us know
what it means
well i appreciate that you had no idea
what it meant you bought it anyway
um
am i going to explain it no
you should know that by now if you
listen to the show we don't explain
anything
lots of very as the last dm said lots of
unintelligible things come out of the
show we don't explain it we just move on
all right going back to the dm says ryan
uh ryan says hey matt was really sorry
to hear that you got coveted and didn't
die
wishing better luck on the next virus
and then another comment says damn you
ugly
i'm i'm starting to regret the whole
idea of going to the dms i think um
this was not the best decision to start
the new year but thank you so much for
those comments we're gonna go back to
the youtube comments after this you know
the phrase do not comply has taken on an
entirely new meaning for the daily wire
this week this friday the supreme court
will convene to hear arguments on the
legal legality legality and
constitutionality of the mandate and
that means this week is going to be
pivotal in our fight against the bind
administration's authoritarian vaccine
mandate we have over now one million
signatures on our do not comply petition
currently but it's vital that the number
increases before friday when you sign
the petition at dailywire.com do not
comply you help us send a message that
the american people will not comply
again head to dailywire.com do not
comply right now and sign the petition
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so for our cancellation today we move
from new year's resolutions to something
even worse the dreaded new year's
reflection
and worst of all the kinds of
reflections inflicted upon us by
middle-aged divorced writers
which are not really reflections but
more rationalizations of their
horrendous lifestyle choices so last
week there were two pieces published in
this genre one in the atlantic by a
woman ironically named honor jones
titled how i demolished my life
then another in the new york times by
heather havraleski titled marriage
requires amnesia
so we'll start briefly with heather
who's who's at least still married
though perhaps not for long and here she
is reflecting on her marriage
and in her reflections she's decided
that the healthiest and wisest course of
action
is to vomit out all of her most bitter
and unseemly thoughts about her husband
and publish them for all the world to
read so here are a few choice morsels
of the vomit disgusting um
she says when encountering my husband
bill in our shared habitat i sometimes
experience him as a tangled hill of
dirty laundry
who left this here i ask myself
and then the laundry gets up to fetch
itself a cup of coffee this is not an
illusion it's clarity until bill has
enough coffee he lies in a jumble on the
couch listening to the coffee maker
waiting for it to usher him from the
land of the undead
he's exactly the same as a heap of
laundry smelly inert almost sentient but
not quite
this is why surviving a marriage
requires turning down the volume on your
spouse so you can barely hear what
they're saying
you must do this not only so you don't
overdose on the same stultifying words
and phrases with it within the first
year but also so your spouse's various
grunts and sneezes and snorts and throat
clearings don't serve as a magic flute
that causes you to wander out the front
door and into the wilderness never to
return
and then after complaining for a while
about the sound that her husband makes
when he sneezes
because this is the kind of stuff that
gets published in the new york times by
the way i mean she literally spends
paragraphs talking about what he sounds
like when he sneezes heather then drops
this she says
do i hate my husband
oh for sure yes definitely
i don't know anyone who's been married
for more than seven years who flinches
at this concept
a spouse is a blessing and a curse
wrapped into one how could it be
otherwise how is hatred not the natural
outcome of sleeping so close to another
human for years
unless you plug a propofol drip into
your arm every single night how do you
encounter those unwelcome grunts and
gravelly snores is anything but
oppressive
unless you spend most of your waking
hours daydreaming how do you tolerate
this meddling presence rearranging stuff
but never actually putting it away
opening bills but never actually paying
them shedding his tissues and his dirty
socks all over your otherwise pristine
habitat
well heather
hello my name is matt uh now we've met
and you can say that you've met at least
one married person who doesn't hate his
spouse and you could probably walk
outside of your house and quite easily
find many more like me
maybe you haven't left your house in a
long time maybe that's part of your
problem i don't know
but what i can say is that hating your
spouse is not normal or okay
anger is one thing like we just talked
about of course you're gonna get ticked
off at your spouse sometimes that's just
an emotion
but to love is to will the good of the
other that means to hate is to will the
bad of the other it's to want bad things
to happen to somebody
and to actively work to make those bad
things happen
this sort of thing has no place in a
marriage i mean that belongs on a
battlefield
or you know on twitter
not in your home not between you and the
person you've vowed your life to
especially when you consider why you
hate your spouse
you know your hatred is wrapped up in a
product of
your self-involvement your narcissism
your ego your fantasies your
self-deceptions
so let's take just one line which i
thought was pretty revealing
um when you said you know
you hate him because he sheds his
tissues and his dirty socks all over
your otherwise pristine habitat
now even if this were true
the fact that you hate somebody for
inconveniencing you only shows that the
problem again is you but also what about
the messes you make
who's to say that your habitat would be
pristine if not for him
and who says that it's your habitat to
begin with see the way you see it you
own everything it's all yours this is
your life your home your marriage not
his
and you're perfect and so anything not
perfect that happens is a direct assault
and a front to you
the problem again is you and probably
him too to some extent but the only
person you can directly fix is yourself
and you haven't even begun to consider
that option yet
which is why your marriage eventually
will fail
unless you figure out how to confront
your own weaknesses but this is all
downright wholesome and healthy compared
to the other piece the one in the
atlantic titled how i demolished my life
the writer honor jones describes how she
rather dishonorably divorced her husband
for no reason other than that she was
bored
she says that she was bored in her house
and boarded her husband
and that's what led to led to this
revelation she says
i didn't have a secret life
but i had a secret dream which might
have been worse
i loved my husband it's not that i
didn't but i felt that he was standing
between me and the world between me and
myself
everything i experienced relationships
reality my understanding of my own
identity and desires were filtered
through him before i could access them
the worst part was that it wasn't
remotely his fault
this is probably exactly what i asked
him to do when we were 21 and first in
love even if i never said it out loud to
shelter me from the elements to be
caring and broad shouldered
but now it was like i was always on my
tiptoes trying to see around him i
couldn't see but i could imagine
i started imagining other lives other
homes
i wanted to be thinking about art and
sex and politics and the patriarchy how
much of my life i mean the architecture
of my life but also its essence my soul
my mind
had i built around my husband
what could i be if i wasn't his wife
maybe i would micro dose maybe i would
have sex with women maybe i would write
a book
god i hope not now these are great
ambitions you see these are these are
her great the great summit she she wants
to climb now that she's free
to have sex with women and micro dose
then she she describes how she told her
husband that she was leaving him for no
reason
and she also throws in that she has kids
too by the way they're an afterthought
of course
their well-being is of no concern to her
whatsoever then she says this
there were days when the magnitude of
what i've done bored down on me i kept
wondering if i'd feel regret or remorse
it's hard to admit this it makes me cold
as cold a woman as my ex-husband
sometimes suspects i am but i didn't i
felt raw and i liked it
there was nothing between me and the
world it was as if i'd been wearing
sunglasses and then taken them off and
suddenly everything looked different not
better or worse just clearer harsher
cold wind on my face
i had caused so much upheaval so much
suffering and for what he asked me that
at first again and again for what
so i could put my face in the wind so i
could see the sun's glare
but i didn't say that out loud
well it's good you didn't say that out
loud i can't imagine being the husband
in that scenario
and my wife has just told me that she's
ruining my life in our kids lives and
destroying everything we've built
and i ask why and she says oh to put my
face in the wind and see the sun's glare
uh what
that doesn't mean anything it literally
doesn't mean anything
and i could read more of this piece to
you but it's all like that none of it
means anything
because it's all just a supremely
shallow self-absorbed narcissistic woman
trying to find poetic language to
obscure the fact that she tore her
family apart because she was bored
she's like a sadistic child pulling the
legs off of a spider for fun except in
this case she's pulling her family apart
ripping it limb from limb
and feeling quite entertained by the
spectacle apparently or at least numb to
it as she confesses
worst of all she thinks this makes her
interesting
but it doesn't
you see shallow selfish people who can't
keep their promises are a dime a dozen
there's nothing fascinating or
provocative about the concept
tolstoy famously begins anna karenina
which is his novel about the 19th
century russian version of you know this
woman honor jones with this line he says
all happy families are alike each
unhappy family is unhappy in its own way
but i think that's exactly backwards
because most unhappy failing marriages
and the unhappy divorced people they
produce are the same
they're usually just a bunch of childish
you know selfish people at the center of
it
the same story repeated a billion times
but intact successful marriages and
families are much more dynamic and
unique and interesting
maybe somebody should write a new york
times or atlantic article about one of
those sometimes
but for now to start the new year
both of those publications who printed
those pieces and the women who were
responsible who wrote them
are of course canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo
vadowsky the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia howe for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire